spingere la pirateria paghi al mese
quello che pagheresti per un singolo
confanetto di serie tv a e lo sai che
netflix non è e probabilmente non sarà
mai disponibile in italia a tassi mio
giovane idiota ho fatto un errore
[Musica]
benvenuti ad una nuova puntata senza
cravatta del leccio con karim usa non è
che posso portarla sempre mi piace
essere un po sciatto ogni tanto tipo
dottor house
ebbene sì nonostante la mia perfezione
visiva ed intellettuale
ho commesso un errore due anni fa avevo
detto che netflix non sarebbe mai
arrivato in italia a quanto pare mi
sbagliavo
un anno fa infatti il popolare sito di
streaming e finalmente arrivato nelle
nostre case
siamo tutti contenti se ad un prezzo
veramente irrisorio al mese possiamo
godere di un parco titoli di tutto
rispetto esattamente come ce lo
aspettavamo circa si è purtroppo una
cosa nel video precedente l'avevo
azzeccata il problema dei diritti molte
cose che su netflix america ci sono da
noi ancora no per esempio house of cards
una delle serie di punta fatta proprio
da netflix da noi assente perché ce l'ha
in mano scali ed è solo uno dei tanti
esempi ma basterà aspettare diamo tempo
al tempo
però mi sono fermato un attimo a
chiedermi quanti altri siti di streaming
illegali ci sono in italia
la risposta è molto più di quello che la
gente crede infatti dal 2014 o passato
ogni mese a provare alcuni di questi
siti a mie spese ovviamente e vorrei
mostrarveli ricordandovi che questo non
è un video sponsorizzato nessuno mi sta
pagando per dire queste cose io lo so
che alcuni voi non riescono ad
assimilare bene questa nozione ci sono
addirittura queste teorie
complottistiche che dicono che io abbia
fatto uscire prima
il video del prodotto baseball e poi
farvi passare il placement della htc vai
in modo da pararmi il culo allora o
siete dei geni del male o fatevi fare
una vasectomia il prima possibile per
l'amor di dio
cercherò di descrivervi questi siti nel
più breve tempo possibile
però senza dirvi prezzi perché non
vorrei diventasse la televendita di
claudio lippi
questi sono i siti in cui negli ultimi
mesi ho speso una quantità di soldi
imbarazzante ma l'ho fatto per il bene
del paese
netflix partiamo con il più famoso
diciamocelo netflix all'inizio è partito
con pochissimi contenuti ma nel corso di
mesi ha espanso il catalogo consegne
film originali e no
non sto neanche a dilungarmi perchè
tanto lo conoscete tutti il mio problema
è dove la roba italiana
la categoria italiani e la tristezza
unica che viene aggiornata col
contagocce idem per quanto riguarda gli
spettacoli comici che vengono chiamati
cabaret e talk show ottimo manca solo il
suo greggio che mi urla le veline
comunque quella categoria e ottima piena
zeppa di comici per la maggior parte
sconosciuta in italia che appunto
possono essere scoperti e gusto a dire a
tutti
e i nostri e non parlo solo dei comici
satirici stendo ap sti cazzi e mazzi ma
ma tutti quanti perché lo mette gli
spettacoli di un maurizio battista o
magari quelli dei monologhisti di zelig
e colorado insieme a quelli dei comici
di satiriasi per dire per il resto ho e
netflix lo sto sinceramente usando molto
più del previsto e questo è un bene
infiniti ha bentornato carissimo come fa
come sta e famiglia tutto a posto
vedo che ti sei ripreso esso ignorato un
sacco bello del via con infiniti cio sto
costante rapporto odio amore odio amore
ma diamo a cesare quel che è di cesare
nell'ultimo anno hanno aggiunto una
marea di contenuti tra i quali per chi
fosse interessato praticamente tutta la
programmazione mediaset
partendo da tu si che vale sa uomini e
donne dal grande fratello vip alle iene
un salutone a frank poi tutte le fiction
tipo squadra mobile squadra antimafia il
capo dei capi
cazzo c'è pure finalmente soli con gerry
scotti e maria amelia monti che non
vedevo dal 92 c'è proprio tutto tutto
tutto tranne camera caffè e allora
ditelo [ __ ] lo vada a posta per il
cinema invece c'è una discreta varietà e
ogni tanto fanno i pacchetti tipo tutti
matrix in aiardi ghostbusters la
trilogia di psycho
ma non so neanche se la vita vera questa
qui è sulla scia di netflix anche
infiniti ha iniziato a produrre
contenuti originali suoi
da una parte abbiamo perdevi
l'agis dei più black better console
marco polo back down luke cage stranger
teens dall'altra mariottide kk rinculo
come per netflix faccio appello a voi o
creatori di infiniti per favore
aggiungete spettacoli di comici nostrani
e non lo dico da stronzo perché in
questo periodo le faccio anch'io lo dico
soprattutto perché noi abbiamo
tantissimi ea volte in dvd sono molto
difficili da trovare
ho visto che avete messo le puntate di
colorado e lo speciale di pintus buono
buono magari proviamo a mettere qualcosa
anche per quelle persone a cui non
bastano delle voci ne per ridere ma è
già qualcosa e sono molto contento sky
on line sky on line e la versione di
streaming online di sky è ed è
attualmente il più debole tra i siti
perché in confronto con gli altri a
pochissimi contenuti e alcuni tra
l'altro sono presi direttamente da
netflix come auto scarda punto ho molti
bei questi poveracci accattoni in
compenso ci sono alcuni canali sky in
diretta che sono sempre ben accetti
e anche i programmi televisivi più visti
attualmente come xfactor italia's got
talent è poi cercate la social la dura
vita delle web star dopo il boom della
prima stagione ci rimettono la farcia ti
basta come risposta se non te la posso
pure ripetere e dulcis in fundo ci sono
le uniche due sedi italiane meritevoli
proprio prodotte da sky romanzo
criminale e gomorra cosa cosa c'è come
dite non trovate più il sito di sky on
line ma è normale perché negli ultimi
mesi ha cambiato faccia per attirare più
gente giovine dalla loro parte si è ri
colorato con tonalità accesissime tipo
fucsia e verde cobalto e si è rinominato
la tv perché noi siamo cool 3b social e
altre parole utili solo ad attirare
ragazzini gli olo swag ma il vero
problema di questo cambio è
l'abbonamento prima era diviso in due
pagamenti
diversi un pacchetto per il cinema è un
pacchetto per le serie tv e programmi
televisivi insieme ora hanno diviso
tutto in treno un pagamento per il
cinema 1 per le serie tv e uno ancora
diverso per i programmi televisivi o sky
ci avete proprio la faccia come il culo
team vision
avete presente tutte quelle chiamate
ricevute dagli operatori tim in cui vi
rompono i [ __ ] con offerte di cui
non avete bisogno per la prima volta
nella mia vita io ne ho accettata una ma
voi ve lo ricordate il vecchio
cubovision no fatti non se lo ricorda
nessuno
beh sappiate solo che ora si chiama tim
vision l'ennesimo portale streaming con
abbonamento mensile ma sapete una cosa
probabilmente starò per bestemmiare
perché sto dicendo cose positive di un
offerta tim potrebbe essere uno dei siti
di streaming migliori in circolazione
attualmente a livello di contenuti alla
categoria cinema che spalle al di sopra
di tutti gli altri soprattutto per i
film italiani anche un sacco di serie
animate e traumi detective conan cazzo
conan è introvabile non esiste neanche
in dvd
però ovviamente come ogni cosa bella
della vita deve fare un passo in avanti
e tre indietro infatti di conan c'è la
stagione 1 11 12 13 14 e 15 guarda mamma
non scontare viti invece un però voglio
specificare la cosa che mi ha spinto a
provarlo che non sono tanto i contenuti
se che sono comunque numerosi ma
l'abbonamento che fai è uno di quelli in
cui quando guardi la roba in giro usando
il 4g non ti fa sprecare gigabyte
questo è il futuro
peccato però che abbiano fatto un passo
in avanti e tre indietro con i siti come
netflix per esempio puoi usare il tuo
abbonamento dappertutto sul cellulare su
pc su tablet su console su smart tv
conti indigeni invece l'abbonamento
funziona solo sul cellulare e su pc
se io volessi collegarlo anche alla
smart tv per esempio mi toccherebbe
pagare un
secondo abbonamento ma perchè perchè
rovinare una cosa bella con l'anci roll
e uno dice che crunchyroll questo è un
sito molto carino che potrebbe
interessare a qualcuno i contenuti di
crunchyroll sono al cento per cento
anime mi sono abbonato per pochissimo
tempo è perché appunto sono contenuti
limitati ad un genere solo io avevo
visto berserk e mi ci sono fidato con un
deficiente mi sono iscritto funziona se
v'interessa provatelo
purtroppo non essendo un vero
appassionato quasi tutti gli altri
titoli mi sembravano roba che di solito
ordino al ristorante giapponese
la battuta di merda vabbè ma se uno è un
poveraccio come me che non ha un soldo
cosa fa
semplice si toglie la vita oppure ci
sono un paio di portali in cui è
possibile vedere il film e serie tv
gratis legalmente
uno fra tutti vivi i vip al costo della
disattivazione diablo che potete godervi
film molto particolari alcune serie tv
tra cui the office inglese little
britain che vi consiglio di vedere e
ovviamente anime questo è il sito che mi
ha fatto conoscere one management per
dire ci sono anche di piccoli show tra
cui perché dovrei guardarlo di dario
roccia perché tu sei un uomo
straordinario dario ecco perché l'altro
sito gratuito invece non è un sito è un
canale di youtube e il canale ufficiale
italiano della yamato animation
non lo so probabilmente lo conoscerete
già ma questo canale carica serie
complete di grandi classici
dell'animazione giapponese e non saprei
cos'altro dirvi sugli amato animations e
non fateci un salto
quindi questi erano i siti che ho
personalmente provato nel corso degli
ultimi due anni
ognuno ha i suoi pregi ei suoi difetti
come giusto che sia e tra tutti non
saprei proprio cosa consigliarvi perché
la scelta si basa ovviamente sul
contenuto è quello dove tre decidono voi
e tra l'altro non ho neanche parlato dei
siti che conosco ma che non sono ancora
arrivate in italia come un avanzo video
però non è che posso fare pubblicità
gratuita a tutti i siti che mi vengono a
suonare sotto casa e mi sono appena
accorto di aver fatto tutto il video col
sacchetto del microfono davanti alla
telecamera [ __ ] eva ma prima di
chiudere il video
nel lasciarvi con un piccolo messaggio
come avete potuto leggere dal titolo c'è
questa frase che alcune persone hanno
proprio trovato gusto a dire questa
parte non è neanche nel copione facciamo
una piccola distinzione c'è chi ha i
soldi e può permettersi un abbonamento
mensile anche più di uno e poi ci sono
le persone che non hanno la possibilità
di avere neanche un abbonamento ma che
rispettano il lavoro degli altri
quindi si scaricano tutti i film e
telefilm manco fossero dei pirati dei
caraibi ma rispettano il lavoro e quindi
i pochi soldi che hanno ogni tanto li
spendono in dvd o libri o cd musicali o
fumetti o videogiochi che sono passioni
costose tutte sempre e questo non lo
mette mai in dubbio nessuno quindi
nessuno viene a dire niente se vi
mettete a scaricare roma tutti scaricano
roma e con questo voglio solo dirvi che
qualsiasi account qualsiasi account di
netflix di infiniti edificio di
qualsiasi sito di streaming con un
abbonamento mensile può essere diviso
fra più persone
se vuoi per esempio dividete la caduta
di netflix con altre tre persone
ve lo portate a casa a due euro al mese
il problema sta nella terza categoria di
pubblico quelli del che cazzo spendo a
fare se posso averlo gratis perché sono
sicuro che voi siete quelle persone che
condividono i video dalle pagine
facebook con le bande nere sopra e sotto
rubati ad altre persone quindi fammi
mettere la grafica giusta farmi mettere
comodo posso parlare
voi pensate di avere ragione ma non
avete ragione voi pensate che l'attore
non sia un vero lavoro
liberissimi di farlo allora volti
scaricare più nessun film
pensi che il disegnatore di fumetti non
sia un vero lavoro bene non ti scaricare
mai più nessuna scanna siete persone
piccole e mi fate veramente girare i
[ __ ]
buona giornata